バレたバレた
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
今ヒカキン親分が事務所のそちらにいます
すぐそこにいます
ヒカキンさん
何が好きか知っていますか？
そう
ヒカキンさんは三度の飯よりサングラスが好きなんです
今回ですね、お店のサングラスを展示台ごと買ってきました
いやー、どうですかね
もう、どれもヒカキンさん好みのサングラスだらけですね
よくわかりませんけど
今回この大量のサングラスじょ
今回この大量のサングラスを使って何をするかと言いますと
ヒカキンさんは
やっぱサングラスに目が無いと思うんです
手あたり次第にサングラスを買っちゃうと思うんで
え、どう思います？
ヒカキンさんがもしサングラスがこうあると
（UUUM社員）パッと見た印象で、「あ、俺どれかけようかな」っていう気持ちなる
あぁ～
もうそこから始まっちゃうんだね
（UUUM社員）そこから始まってびっくりというかどれにしようかなぁ
あぁ～なるほどもう考えにはいってしまうと
（UUUM社員）はいっちゃうかな
親分家行くたび変なことやってるんで警戒して感度高いと思うんですけど
親分の家にね、大量のサングラスを
こう列に並べて、あるじゃないですか
なんかチーズをさ置いて動物をおびき寄せるみたいな
ヒカキンさんはサングラスでおびき寄せることはできるのか
実験してみたいと思います
では、行こう
あー、おやすみなさい
お疲れ様です
（スマホ）これから色々な謝罪をしていこうかなと思います
仕掛けていきます
よし
ヒカキンさんはサングロス
サングラスが好きすぎてサングラスでおびき寄せられるのかどうか
実験してみようと思います
（ノックの音）
（ドアが閉まる音）
んっ、なんだ
なんだこれ、サングラスがいっぺーあんなこれ
なんだなんだなんだなんだ
なんだよなんだよなんだよ
なんだよ、怖ーな
なんだなんだなんだ
ん、なんだこれ
お金？
なんだよ、怖ーよ
んっ、おいおいなんだ
百、百三円
（はじめ）ヒカキンさんはサングラスが大好きなんで
サングラスでおびき寄せられるかどうかっていう
いやー見事にヒカキンさんやっぱサングラス好きだから引っかかりましたね
いやいや
（ヒカキン）なんなのこの１０３円
（はじめ）あ、これは賞金です
ていう訳でで検証の結果やっぱりヒカキンさんはサングラスが大好きだったということでございます
（はじめ）バーイ
（ヒカキン）バーイ
（はじめ）すいません夜中に